in tonight's final it's india versus
britain as two outstanding chefs battle
it out for the title of the f word's
best local restaurant
their challenge is to come up with three
stunning dishes made with jani street
porter's delicious pork beef and chicken
my first finalist tonight is la san from
birmingham
[Music]
when i first walked in the door at la
san i could send straight away that it
was something special nice atmosphere
it was cool contemporary and stylish we
were the first restaurant to break away
from the mainstream and offer
alternatives to your bolts and your
tikka masalas that's exquisitely
presented
vanessa actor how are you i'm very
welcome in the kitchen i discovered head
chef akhtar swimming against the tide
refusing to serve up familiar indian
crowd pleasers like chicken tikka masala
what's the ambition lasan what is it
it's not food for
people who haven't got an educated
palette it is a very sophisticated
cuisine
there's something very special about la
sam's dishes and they serve me some of
the best food i've tasted outside india
the murk mahoney and the butter chicken
absolutely delicious melt in your mouth
and yeah
authentic but my winner tonight must
also be committed to delivering the very
best service to its customers
so for the semi-finals lassan had to
undergo three grueling tests
first up i sent in secret diners
is it possible to change it
too hot for me sorry
oh thank you
attentive service yeah good
and then 30f where diners visited la san
putting aktar's kitchen under immense
pressure
[Music]
how much longer can you give me a time
at least 10 minutes at least
he's got to get a grip there's a
customer set upstairs
minus the main course which is not good
enough
akhtar is very confident and sometimes
he can be a bit too cocky for his own
good
how'd you find the money chef
i thought the food was outstanding
doesn't mean
go finish
sorry
but i love his ingenuity and his
fearless determination to take risks
with his cooking
pedigree and saffron for the potatoes no
the saffron's actually in the uh the
gravy and the gravy yeah that's right in
the third test at my flagship restaurant
at royal hospital road akhtar revealed
his more sensitive side
we've always been knocked
for our approach by people within our
industry
[Music]
you
for
pushing the barrier
wow
absolutely phenomenal you taste it and
it blows your mind away
my other finalists tonight couldn't be
more different the pheasant from rural
cambrisher
as soon as i set foot in this rustic
restaurant i was completely seduced by
the warm atmosphere that husband and
wife team jay and taffeta have created
let me get you a menu
very cozy those ceilings beautiful
buildings from the outside
that's roof and feels and looks and
smells british
the pheasant is a slice of paradise in
the heart of the english countryside we
have customers that sort of would just
turn up and throw abrasive pigeon down
or the other day we had a guy gone
shooting for some mallard we trade off
we might cook them a duck supper and
that's payment for it really they just
don't want to see
anything wasted
the pheasant serves wonderful british
food and hfj is so devoted to the local
produce he gets his ingredients from the
farm next door
we've got the cows and you know we've
got pigs and all that sort of stuff we
cook everything of the animal especially
like all the awful you know i love offal
so why not use it partridge you know
tough bird to cook they go dry within
seconds so uh yeah that was delicious
my team of secret diners confirmed that
the pheasant was just as good when i
wasn't there would you prefer
they're good
and when i turned up with my coach of f
word diners they cope brilliantly yes
service is friendly attentive again and
everyone's little busy bodies running
around making sure bread butter water
and constantly observing which is always
nice jay's a very controlling chef very
hands-on but everything functions around
him
he's at the sort of central point on the
hot plate and everything comes up to him
so he misses nothing everything's
scrutinized overseen tasted as well
a good sign
when things do go wrong however jay's
head can drop it's [ __ ] hard
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay
yeah just sat too long or
rested like that needed to be on a rack
[ __ ] one day it [ __ ] matters and
we can't do it [ __ ] properly
but in the semi-final at royal hospital
road jay proved once again what a
fantastic chef he is
does it work
my god
that's amazing
now lassan and the pheasant face one
last test
tonight they'll be batting out for the
title the f word's best local restaurant
service is about to start and this is
gonna be the fight of their lives
i will have the final say on who wins so
who's it going to be it's too close to
call
only one can win this needs to be the
best service of your lives tonight we're
going to be crowning the f word's best
local restaurant it's indian versus
british
in tonight's final the pheasant from
cambridgeshire and la san from
birmingham are battling out in the
f-word restaurant in their toughest
challenge yet
they're cooking their own recipes using
beef pork and chicken that janet street
porter has provided from her farm in
yorkshire
who will like crown the f word's best
local restaurant
[Applause]
wow
right
first of all welcome back what an
amazing journey it's been for all four
of you to be here in the final really
well done right jay how you feeling
anxious welcome back to guy thank you
actor how you feeling very good chef um
yeah i'm ready to go gentlemen one of
you okay who's gonna win the title of
the f words best local restaurant
tonight
there's one shot at this no rehearsal
personally the journey has been
phenomenal i am so glad that both
restaurants are back here tonight why
because you both deserve heavily to be
here i've packed the dining room
purposely okay with food writers critics
from all over the country they are a
tough budget just have a look at them
look at their faces
this is the final
their comments are absolutely critical
but i will be deciding
who is the winner now make it your
nights okay each restaurant is going to
make 25 portions of their starter then
you're each going to do 50 portions of
your unique main course and then back to
25 portions of the dessert each yes
so really make it work yes
let's go
excellent
okay let's send first off here four
covers away to everyone four chicken
yeah four beef four dessert
no answer huh yes chef sorry when you
give me that level of confidence
shout out yes sir yes sure i turn my
back i can continue when it's silent you
haven't got it you know the school
you've been here yeah let's start again
i don't wanna [ __ ] it was table one yes
last sound here we go first ticket four
chicken four beef for dessert yes chef
hassan yes sir thank you welcome back
both brigades are cooking with animals
from janet's farm here's la san starter
with street porter chicken
actor's been on an amazing journey
during this competition
in the semi-final the cocky arrogant
facade finally cracked
i was so disappointed with the way
things went i thought you know i've lost
it and that was it but then when chef
turned around and he said i've made it
through to the finals with my team you
know it's absolutely amazing and you
know once again i broke into uh tears
so i won't be able to walk into a local
anymore without having the piss taken
out of me there's an order for that
tonight is chicken tandoori masala with
mint chutney
first akhtar rubs the chicken with
garlic and a ginger paste we're trying
to get as much flavor into
the chicken as possible next he makes
the marinade most marinades always start
off with mustard oil so here it goes
next he adds ground cumin tandoori
masala garam masala
ground fennel seeds and white pepper
then he adds coriander
coats the chicken and leaves it to
marinade i think this marinade is
definitely going to quite wonders for
janet's chicken
actor then fries the marinaded chicken
to seal it
just trying to get a bit of colour on it
and finishes cooking in a hot oven for
about eight minutes
he serves with a salad in a coriander
dressing and mint chutney
this is typical aktar he's fantastic at
using great presentation to take indian
food to another level
chicken tadori masala with mint chutney
served
now even from here yeah that smells
delicious
tonight you know that hey guys taste
taste taste yes asan everything you do
you taste yeah nice did you go foraging
for them our man did you know he's
foraging for us
a nice phone call for me at midnight
last night saying what good news or bad
news telling me to tell you that you got
stung picking them by wild bees we got
stunned by wild bees at midnight what
the [ __ ] we're doing right in the middle
of winter was he somewhere he shouldn't
have been i think he might have been the
pheasant are using janet's pork for
their starter
head chef jane has upped his game at
each stage of the competition he likes
to use every part of the animal so for a
starter he's going to use the pig's head
to make a brawn quite an ambitious dish
it's really important not to waste waste
a thing so you've got to be inventive in
how you're going to scrape the bones
down to make a train or or whatever you
know that's what we practice here
the pheasant is what life is all about
we do put everything into it you know
[Applause]
i want to be the best
i want
that accolade of being gordon ramsay's
best local restaurant check on one
check on one prawn
the pheasant starter tonight is brawn
with crisp pork belly
to make the brawn jay cooks the pig's
head with vegetables herbs spices and
pig shotters
rawn is a traditional english coarse
pate once cooked he removes all the
flesh from the bones along with some of
the skin you'll be surprised the amount
of meat that there is actually within
the head see that's that's the cheek you
know there lovely little nugget of meat
to flavor the brawn he adds parsley
green peppercorns and mixed spices
[Applause]
jay uses half the brawn to make the
capacio the other half is breaded and
deep fried
jay's braun capacio is served with
hard-boiled egg baby leeks and a chopped
apple salad
finally the dish is finished with a
slice of fried pork belly
brown with crisp pork belly
served
hey tell me about the recipe well braun
is born yeah uh the reason for the
carpaccio just to sort of lose the ick
factor yeah they're ladies really i mean
it's a very robust
yeah
you know if they're all foodies though
if they even if they don't like the idea
of brawn they'll try it and i'm sure if
they try it they'll like it okay guys
well done yeah they look fantastic you
happy with those yes sure yeah yeah yeah
they look amazing yeah really really
good now we're doing five servers please
go next yeah first time why are you
slicing it upside down colored side
presentation side down
yeah presenter
no no the other way
precise from the presentation side have
you not been watching me actor joe's got
tablet already but it's not a race yes
this is not a race yeah it's all about
getting it right come on listen please
no problem i've got to put it up there
this way now
actor happy man i'm very happy with you
happy yes good very nice they smell
delicious by the way thank you very much
absolutely delicious love the colors
servers please nice and gentle on the
plates four on table one please yeah
are they gonna stick stand by yeah
yes yeah actually they look fantastic
love the smell
the chicken dish was really close to
being a great dish but it just wasn't
quite there in the spicing there was
just too much chilli and therefore they
lost the
harmony of the dish the chicken was
excellent um it was really really moist
really juicy and tender and i think
it's fantastic because it's on the bone
and that's really where the flavor comes
from i love the mint and coriander
chutney jay you're a big lover of indian
food it's my favorite cuisine is it
really yeah i love it i love it tonight
if you lose
we're getting promised me a free meal
i thought the pork was really it melted
in the mouth it was cooked to perfection
the crackling was lovely and then
against the tartness of the apples and
the sweetness of the leeks it was lovely
the compaction was quite fatty the small
crispy squares were quite fatty
fat done very well but also
you know there's a little bit too much
of it
really vibrant start in there jay's got
off to a very confident composed
energetic start keeping himself to
himself but focusing on these flavors
that dish is very very ambitious akhtar
however has sort of he's come in almost
lack of confidence which is a big change
around for him but more importantly he
started to communicate to his sous chef
like he cares which is a really positive
sign who's in the lead right now this is
neck and neck
welcome to you both you look amazing
thank you
thank you very much how are you i'm fine
now java he seems to eat drink sleep
breathe food is he workaholic he is here
very much in fact
i don't know how he does it but he does
it well and i think that's largely
supported by the amount of passion he
has for food and what he does yeah jabba
is making money at him so he's not
particularly bothered about him being a
workaholic do you have any concerns
about the level of commitment that guy
puts into his cooking there is concerns
i always ask him to lighten up and you
know either but i think that's his
passion and that's where you get the
best of actor but i've out of all this
sport and i have to thank you he has
changed he's he's simmered down he's
calmed down i think he's more um he
takes on you know positive criticism
good luck thank you i'm pretty good
thank you enjoy my course thank you jim
my goodness me how are you feeling i'm
feeling uncentered nervous incredibly
excited everything he is very calm yet
again in there what is it with this guy
that cooks in that unassuming calm style
i have no idea but i have to say he is
looking incredibly calm today it looks
like he's enjoying it today which is
another thing yeah now what's he been
like over the last seven days to deal
with i finally asked
a blessing would you love him more if he
wins yeah
really enjoy your main courses um and
you both look great thank you very much
thank you
tonight i'm deciding the winner
i'm gonna be judging jane actor's dishes
by my highest standards
and every dish they cook needs to do
justice to janet's fantastic meat
janet
now
uh great job thank you really good job
the mangalyta pig is quite rare having
had the royal berkshires and yeah
i was excited about it i've never tasted
anything well it was a real talking
point in the valley because obviously
they've never seen these pigs in our
part of north yorkshire loads of people
came to see them and when i showed them
in the show they were really really
popular yeah and they had great
personalities they really did freddie
what were the individual characters like
a bit evil be serious so you got on well
yes i did i bonded with them and they
ran around very very fast and they're
like rolling and mud they were very
entertaining talking about the chickens
wasted time oh no
on rather talk to my cabbages and talk
than
come
to a chicken
or you
the meat tastes great yeah but as an
experience they're not that rewarding
um beef extraordinary stuff dense
delicious and quite a unique flavor i
think that is because the animals run
around a lot more they they've got their
little short legs but they're out shy it
was interesting in our valley because
you could see the other cattle in the
other fields munching away yeah and my
textures were much more lively um again
another amazing job yeah yeah from the
chickens the pork and now the beef thank
you it was really really worthwhile and
i'm glad you enjoyed it because there
would have been nothing worse than to go
through all that nightmare and come up
with me it was average yeah but it was
coming to russians in the final you've
made their life a lot easier producing
fantastic meat like that thank you so
much i've got a present for you you've
got all ready this is a rug
from one of the dexter's seriously it's
a rug type saxon basically gordon so
it's the kind of rug that people put in
front of the phone the history of my
cooking career i never thought i'd touch
janet street porter's rug
give me this thank you
brilliant absolutely amazing job well
done and exquisite produce ladies and
gentlemen round of applause for janice
reporter amazingly thank you
well done thank you much appreciated
thank you
right can't wait to taste the pheasant
starter it looks fantastic like the
little mangalits of pigs been running
around the back garden phenom very
cheffy
now the taste
flavor's amazing you can really identify
that pig is unique the brawn delicious
you've got the crispness of the deep
fried little beignets very earthy very
dense and slightly sweet
it needed that mustard mayonnaise to
really sort of bring it together yeah
they've done that mangalitsa very proud
delicious really good i want to see what
actors is like now he's got the chicken
drum marinated smells amazing and the
breasts sort of char grilled honestly i
thought i'd see chicken tikka from aktar
that's delicious i mean really good it's
the kind of dish i'd expect aktar to
come up with because it's it's packed
with flavor it's very mellow very
cleverly put together and more
importantly it has great finesse from
start to finish looking at both dishes
this is a tough one because that is jay
through and through and this
chicken here is aktar through through
which one do i prefer it's hard to call
i like them both if i had to choose one
i'd go for actor's chicken
we've got 50 food critics out there i
mean you get one or two at the
restaurant and you just happen to find
that and that's it you know you're all
over the place and you know making sure
everything's okay double checking
everything triple checking everything i
am a bit nervous but fingers crossed
we'll do it every dish went out
looks pretty let's just hope they want
to try something different braun pig's
head it's quite not controversial but
hopefully they'll be brave
if the diners don't like the starters
they don't have to pay but it's still
only a guide for me
okay before i get the results okay from
the dynasty i want to let you all know
they are an indication at the end of the
day it's my decision uh jay how you
feeling there's a lot of ladies in the
audience
so um
maybe it don't appeal to every lady but
you know do not like ladies i know they
don't like pork but i don't like popcorn
yeah i love ladies out of 25 how old do
you think you did
i'd like to get 25 but 20 will be fine
yeah brilliant actor you seem to have a
lot more confidence this time around in
terms of opening up and communicating
where's that coming from all of a sudden
through this experience obviously i've
started to talk more and uh and we're
talking back to each other so yeah it
helped yeah you were having a
conversation earlier all about the food
how nice is that great change so out of
25 what do you reckon uh let's say 20
20. oh coffee then interesting uh jb
these are the toughest dinos we've ever
had trust me serious foodies with strong
opinions okay let's start with
pheasant the number of customers out of
25 that are happy to pay for your
starter
is
[Music]
15
huh
15.
not brilliant i'm not bad
jb what do they like um the fun is very
very well presented great in flavors 10
guests didn't enjoy
the pork too fatty too fatty oh come on
of course it's fatty
right lassen the number of customers
they're happy to pay
for your chicken
is
[Music]
22 well done
really good indeed 22 hours great start
very good start
what do they like chicken very tender
tender chicken yes marinated beautiful
um the marinade great great taste right
jay i do not want to see your head go
down now you bounce back 15 out of 25
yeah it's not a terrible score yeah yeah
so stay with it yeah yeah yeah yeah
actor great start don't let that go
upstairs yeah you've each got 50 main
courses to cook now yeah make it count
yeah yeah well done yeah stay down let's
get ready for the next course well done
tonight we're going to be crowning the f
words best local restaurant who's it
going to be
thousands of your favorite local
restaurants were whittled down to 18.
and now there are just two fantastic
finalists
[Applause]
british russian the pheasant from
cambridgeshire
and indian wrestling from birmingham
in the starter i was impressed by jay's
ambition
the train and pork belly both had great
flavor but the brawn capacio was a step
too far for some diners
akhtar played its safe with his starter
tandoori chicken with mint chutney it
was delicious and definitely a popular
choice but i would like to have seen
something a little bit more adventurous
in the end it's my opinion that counts
tonight and there are still two courses
to go
so if jay wants to stay in the game it's
essentially keeps calm and confident
yeah that's tough that jay yeah yeah and
the chef welders are kicking the balls
but you got to stand stand strong up
there yes absolutely yeah liam i don't
want you dropping your head no chance
yeah let's go
right now both restaurants are gonna
cook their main course first up the
pheasant
the pheasants hfj needs to stage a
comeback with his main course he loves
cooking with british meat and he's got
ambitious plans for janet's decks to
beef
i like all the braising and all that
sort of wintery stuff that's the food i
like cooking and i love eating it as
well check out one deck to three ways
check out one dexter three ways please
the pheasant's main course tonight is
beef three ways with beetroot and
horseradish puree mash and pickled red
cabbage
jay's recipe uses a combination of rib
shoulder blade and bravely the heart
we get the whole animal we use the whole
animal for the shoulder blade jay fry's
chunks of beef that'll be marinated in
red wine with vegetables
so you want to sear these lots of color
keeping the juices in we then fry the
beef with vegetables and bay leaves he
returns the meat to the pan and leaves
it to cook slowly with red wine and veal
stock
[Music]
next jay slices the heart and grills
serving heart is a real risk i think it
can be delicious but it's not to
everyone's taste the heart is so with
pickled red cabbage beetroot and
horseradish puree
big bold flavors the earthiness of the
beetroot and then the kick-ass heat of
the horseradish next the river beef jay
seasons the rib and fries
adds butter yeah i like butter and it's
going to give it good flavor and puts it
in the oven to finish cooking
for the sauce jay fry's finely chopped
vegetables adds fried onion lardons and
the cooked shoulder blade and its sauce
this dish is classic j sophisticated
comfort food with amazing attention to
detail
but it's very complicated
makes life a bit harder but
not supposed to be easy finally the
mashed potatoes
then j plates up
this is hearty rustic food but the
presentation's refined
he adds the mushrooms
a chunk of beef rib pickled red cabbage
the beef shoulder
and jay's big gamble
nice piece of heart
and finally the beetroot and horseradish
puree
[Music]
dexter beat three ways
served
uh jay start off in olive oil you're
basing with the butter get it all nice
and sealed yeah and again you seem to
love that way three ways well what are
you gonna do with the heart put it in
the bin yeah no not at all a lot of
chefs will take the easy route and just
cook it one way i love that level of
ambition it's not supposed to be easy is
it
definitely not no
not to become the f1 best local
restaurant you're absolutely right
okay actor you got six now after the six
got four please yeah yeah chef we're
good
here's what la san are cooking tonight
[Music]
akhtar has complete confidence in the
modern exciting food he serves up at
lasan
i'd say we're pioneers in that you know
understanding indian food for what it is
we've got food from south india we've
got food from west bengal north india
kashmir and pakistan so we've got
india on a plate really when you dine at
lasan
[Music]
masala beef table 14. thank you
masala beef
latin's main course tonight is masala
beef with curried pumpkin and a cardamom
scented sauce
[Music]
first act our marinade medallions of
rump steak
it's a light tandoori style marinade so
it's a good all-round mix janet's put a
lot of care and attention into uh
ruining this wonderful meat for us and i
think it's just a befitting end for us
to take as much care
as possible in uh cooking it up
next akhtar makes the masala sauce with
green cardamoms
we grind all of our spices we make all
of our own pastes so that's another
thing that sets us apart to make the
current pumpkin he heats mustard oil in
a pan adding cumin and coriander seeds
then he puts in garlic onion salt ground
turmeric and chili
along with chopped tomatoes
actor adds the diced pumpkin and water
[Music]
once the pumpkin is soft he finishes
with chopped coriander
he fries the marinaded beef for a couple
of minutes on each side
just before serving he stirs in cashew
nut paste
once again akhtar shows real flair with
his presentation
masala beef with curried pumpkin and a
cardamom scented sauce
served
and you're using the eye of the rum
yes chef yeah i'm marinading first get
married it's pretty light marinade and
what we've done with the cashews have
you toasted them uh dry toasted and then
uh just splits down with a bit of water
[ __ ] sake son
how am i supposed to if this f is facing
the customer am i going to put the beef
behind them huh they said
what they say yeah against the f against
the f one o'clock one o'clock that's
that's not one o'clock at three o'clock
i do not have a watch yeah one o'clock
yes
the masala beef i thought was fantastic
that it was a beautiful piece of beef it
just melted in the mouth there was an
explosion of taste particularly with the
pumpkin traditionally you don't really
see beef
in curry dishes it was an incredibly
good cut of beef and very very well
cooked tonight's tonight yeah yes chef
yours looks plain and delicious jay's
looks refined well i've gone for plain
and delicious because the battering
you've given me over the last few months
about about garnishing
are you feeling less confident because
jay's gone for me three ways not just
the heart
the blade you know and then the rib
more isn't always uh better is it i like
to say less is more so i'm hoping on
lessons more today so you're confident
these two things in the bowl tonight can
beat seven things on jay's plate jay's
got a fantastic plate i'm not going to
say anything other than that because it
is amazing i tasted it earlier on but
most admiration for it but i'm hoping
you know simplicity will win through i
mean the fact the marriage of the uh the
pumpkin with the cardamom gravy yeah and
the way the beef has been uh marinated
i'm hoping people will recognize that he
took a lot of skill and uh understanding
to put that together those two fantastic
they smell amazing yeah again perfect
yeah i come to them with the beef okay
let's do it yeah yep uh beautiful
i could lift that now
and run down to royal hostel road and
put it out on table seven it looks
amazing good yeah really good
the dexter bee three-ways was a
wonderful uh plate full of um ideas i
don't know if it quite came together
as um as an overall dish next to three
ways the different textures of beef were
fabulous full marks
i loved it
this is amazing because jay's dish is
very accomplished a very very difficult
dish to pull off beef three ways very
bold move not everyone wants to go out
especially in the f-word dining room and
eat heart beautifully grilled but it's
clearly obvious he's putting his heart
and soul on that plate actor started
with such confidence yeah there's only
three things on his plate this amazing
cashew sauce spiced pumpkin and then a
really nice eye of rib of beef so
quite interesting he's calm
very very confident but he's letting the
food do the talking tonight which is
which is refreshing
upon apologize somebody please yeah yeah
all right
leaving a piece of clinvar on the plate
is a sign that jay's really feeling the
pressure i hope this is just a one-off
mistake
right seriously excited about toasting
both main courses let's start off with
the sand it doesn't look like the kind
of dish should cook normally because
it's just so simple but tonight is
depending on the flavors
rump done with a wonderful sauce with
toasty cashew
and a spiced pumpkin puree
only three things on the plate there and
they complement each other absolutely
brilliantly well delicious if i've got
one complaint
in how aptar puts food together the base
of the bowl is always coated in far too
much sauce it doesn't need all that
great flavors great balance
j's look at it i mean it's beautiful
glamorous and
it oozes
passion so the braised blade
slowly cooked
and reheated in the cooking juices
taste that one first
wow
melts in your mouth
the heart
it's a shame you go from the braised
blade
of dexa's beef to the heart the beef and
it doesn't hold the same kind of quality
in terms of taste a little bit rubbery
as well
what a shame the rib
lovely so two out of three things work
unfortunately one that doesn't grab me
is the grilled heart what a shame
getting 50 dishes out was hard work you
know each little piece of meat needed
100 attention we're in the final we
wanted to win today you know we don't
want second place at the moment it is it
is very close i look at them and you
know find similarities between us both
ultimately it's gonna be chef's decision
i think it's gonna be the toughest one
for him
so uh i feel sorry for chef
i'm deciding the winner tonight but the
diners opinions will help me make up my
mind
right uh how old do you think you did
last time around the f-word kitchen 40
out of 50. paid tonight mid-40s chef
mid-40s midfour is 45 out of 50. i'd
like to see that i love that confidence
it's oozing back in again isn't it yeah
right jay
uh well we need 50. yeah got to beat 36.
yeah for my last one and then need seven
on them so
45. jb please
excellent thank you
right that's them first yeah
the amount of customers that happy to
pay for your main course
out of 50
is
39 out of 50. well done
really well done
really well done
good
very good indeed
okay
well done 3950 good score
yeah jb what do they like um they love
the pumpkin they love the pumpkin
delicious spicy yeah the 11 people that
didn't like it why um mainly because
they said um
the sauce was a bit bland the sauce is a
bit black
ready i thought it was delicious jay
yeah
pheasant
loved the colors loved it work of art
clearly now the number of customers that
are happy to pay for your main course
out of 50
is
wow
28 out of 50.
28 out of 50. no
what's all that about too complicated
that's 22.
yeah as well yes he didn't like the the
heart they didn't like the heart what do
you mean they didn't like the heart it
was a heart salad yeah but
maybe you should just put the heart in
the bin then
yeah and the meat slightly overcooked
the meat slightly overcooked which one
the uh
i thought the dish was amazing
loved the composition and to have the
balls to stick a heart salad on
a plate in the middle of the most
amazing beef extraordinary yeah
remember one thing tonight i will have
the final say i've got a lot to think
about yeah
and you still got to cook 25 desserts
each so
make them perfect okay impress me
impress the diners
one final hurdle yeah yeah well done
clear down let's go ready for dessert
good
next on tonight's menu can the brigades
hold the nerf for the final showdown
come on guys actually melting please
please please ice cream's gotta go on
last you could take that long put it on
the plate yeah
and i'll be facing one of the toughest
decisions i've ever had to make who
shall i crown the f word's best local
restaurant
the restaurant that has consistently
delivered in every mark
across the board
is tonight it's the final in our search
for the f word's best local russian we
had ten thousand nominations we're down
to the final two
la san and the pheasant are battling out
in the final to decide the epword's best
local restaurant
i want to be first i want the trophy
there's only one place for us and that
is winning it
i'm going to decide the winner not just
on tonight's service but how they
performed throughout the past few weeks
so far tonight jay's ambitious dishes
have divided diner opinion
but akhtar is playing it safe and his
brilliance hasn't always shone through
[Music]
[Applause]
the competition is neck and neck and
heading into dessert there's everything
to play for
[Applause]
this was the pheasant's strongest course
in the british heat 23 or 24.
but lasan have been less consistent with
this course 12 out of 25.
who's got the edge there's only one more
course before i decide the winner
guys final round yes
everything's still yeah to cook for okay
it can be won or lost on this course
please focus go for it yeah jay actor
good luck let's go last round
25 desserts here we go
the pheasant's head chef jane had a
tough time with his starter and maine
tonight but he's hoping to pull things
back with a french twist on a classic
british apple pie
what's the point of coming second there
is no second you know you may as well
you know be last it's you you've got to
you've got to win check on one task
check on one tart to tan please
the pheasant dessert is tart to tan to
start j pills and cause apples the
apples you want to use are braeburn
apples they're a firmer texture he lines
the saucepan with sugar and leaves it on
the heat to caramelise we've got a knob
of butter just going to put in it makes
it a bit richer it helps it get that
sort of butterscotchy taste he lays the
apples in a pan and lets the caramel
darken
next jay rolls out puff pastry if you
roll the pastry too thin you get you
don't get much of a rice keep it quite
fat you're going to get a better rice
he puts the pastry lid over the apples
and places the pan in a hot oven for 15
minutes
jay serves a dessert with a dusting of
icing sugar and a scoop of vanilla ice
cream
the pheasant's tartar tan
served
jacob yeah you pull it back on this one
in terms of numbers yeah
yeah liam yeah yeah head up
please be careful tipping them out in
mid-air yeah guys yeah
winning tonight means everything to
actor and dessert is his last chance to
prove himself to me
i'm just zoned into winning and that is
gonna be it it's gordon ramsay choosing
the best local restaurant i mean dream
come true for me doesn't sum it up i
think that that's too blase and the
words i can't find but i know what it
means to me and i know how important it
is to me and everyone around me knows
how important because i've been an
absolute bastard to be around for the
last few months
of parcel gents
la sant's dessert tonight is half a
parcels with strawberry coulee and
vanilla ice cream
act our cooks cassia bark cardamom pods
and bay leaves in clarified butter half
as a traditional north indian
more so punjabi style of pudding
he then cooks grated carrot until soft
akhtar is brilliant at reinventing
classic indian dishes but this harbour
is a risk because it won't be to
everyone's taste
next actor pours in carrot juice and
adds chopped cashew nuts chopped
pistachio nuts and mixes the thing with
this helper is you've got to
continuously uh stir it and keep it
moving otherwise it will catch and it
will burn and that's the end of it then
akhtar pours in cream
milk and finally stirs in sugar
[Music]
he takes the puff pastry parcels and
fills them with the halva mixture
the parcels are then wrapped in silver
foil and baked in a hot oven
[Music]
then octar plates up
finishing the dish with ice cream and a
strawberry
half a parcel with strawberry coulee and
vanilla ice cream
served
[Music]
i'm trying to put that sauce on the
plate first so the mouth screw doesn't
melt i want the ice cream melting at the
table yeah so not in the kitchen
come on guys that's please melting
please please please ice cream's gonna
go on last you could take that long put
it on the plate yeah
go good
let's go so ice cream on last guys yeah
otherwise trust me first table five but
three four tables down the line ice
cream's gonna be pissing all over the
plate yeah
now the pheasant looks fantastic again
two very lucky people getting to share
this it's huge
touch of ice cream tatan
wow simplicity at its best rainbow
apples puff pastry butter sugar
delicious really nice the important part
about putting this dish together is
every little bit of technical ability
has to be spot on now lassans however
classic dessert
spiced carrot wrapped in pastry baked in
the oven
smells very fragrant
cardamom cinnamon
pastry just a little bit doughy and
slightly undercooked and it's not very
sweet but it's not very spicy so the
jury's out in that one i'm not entirely
sure
it doesn't blow me away if i had to
choose between both of these desserts
there's a clear winner by a mile and
it's from the pheasant
just when it looked like jay had lost
his confidence he comes back with a
winning dessert but tonight is down to
me not the diners that choose a winner
there's so much at stake here and i know
just how much both restaurants really
want this
we're not prepared to go to go second
yeah i don't want to lose i want to go
first i don't want to go back home and
tell all our staff that we lost
so
every point counts and there's only
first place
we want to win it and you know to a
certain extent we have to win it that's
the way we've put it to ourselves so it
is important to us
fingers crossed
the dessert scores are in tonight i'm
going to read them in private before
making my decision about who deserves to
win the f worth best local restaurant
so desserts blimey uh that's a sharp
lasagna out of 25.
nine customers are happy to pay that's a
big shock i knew the car was lacking in
spice and slightly dull pastry
undercooked however the pheasant scored
18 out of 25.
that's a phenomenal performance on
dessert for them and more importantly
did they pull it back yes of course they
pulled it back this
is a very close call
[Music]
la sam is everything a great local
indian should be and there are flashes
of real genius in aktar's cooking
[Music]
the pheasant is a fantastic local
restaurant great british food and a
wonderful atmosphere
two
very talented chefs and based on
everything i've seen and witnessed and
tasted from both chefs
there is
a winner
and one of them just edges it this has
been a very tough decision in the making
but i can put them out their misery and
let them know
[Music]
before i give results for desserts yeah
tonight's overall winner does not depend
entirely on the numbers from the dining
room they're a guide clearly influential
guide and they're going to help me
decide
but i will have the final say on who
wins the f words best local restaurant
and here's the thing actor asan jay liam
i'm taking every little ounce of detail
into account what a journey for all of
us
you've done phenomenally well
really well done
jake how you feeling
bit down why
well rubbish scores the food delivered
i mean really delivered
absolutely
delicious
yeah great textures
and visually yeah it had an impact
really good good thank you actor
how you feeling um i'm feeling a good
chef it was a very tough challenge for
us today because obviously uh beef is
not something that we used to cook and
we've had to create something for
today's final so and that went down very
well so that you know that's comforting
now here are the diner scores
lesson
the number of diners that are happy to
pay for your dessert out of 25
is nine
desserts
clearly well not your strong point
jay
the number of diners happy to pay for
your dessert out of 25
18 out of 25 well done really well done
really well done
yeah
yeah yeah
really well done
so
lassan
70 out of 100
well done
yeah well done that's good very good
indeed
jay
out of 100 the fed has scored 61 out of
100 another good score
well done to both of you seriously both
restaurants did a fantastic job tonight
but who is the f words best local
restaurant
this gentleman has been a very tough
decision to make and it's not just about
the scores it's from the start to finish
round one
secret diners
turning up
jumping in from a coach
royal hostel road
customer feedback numbers everything i
have scrutinized
the winner
of the f words best local restaurants
is
[Music]
the restaurant that has consistently
delivered in every mark
across the board
is
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Applause]
an absolute pleasure having you in the
kitchen now get out and get yourself an
amazing drink well done
well done
well done well done well done
[Applause]
it's an amazing sensation
oh
god
it'd be like the cheshire cat from now
on i'm hugely proud of jay we're both
incredibly gutted we're stuck to what
the pheasant is about and um you know
we got this far we've got to take the
positives out of there you know i'm
chuffed i'm suffering
has an exciting and creative chef in
akhtar and the standards of excellence
i've been searching for in a local
restaurant
for me that's what this extraordinary
competition has been all about finding
that passion on every level
i know actor feels honoured to lift the
trophy tonight and i'm just as proud to
name la san the winner